live look at vice president great job
tonight VP Pence
great job thank you sir
good job yeah
[Music]
straight up lied to his face
but that's what politics is just
straight up not into people's face told
me did a great job he didn't
told him that he won the debate he did
not
politics 101 retail politics
foreign
people we are at a different time but
I'm still the same Dave Rubin also in a
different Studio on the other coast of
the United States of America that's
right I'm here at the prageru studios in
Los Angeles in Crazy Comey California
today September a 28th 2023 and we are
here for a couple days because yes I was
at the Republican debate the second
Republican debate last night at the
Reagan Library in Simi Valley that cold
open we did that was my man Adam sosnick
from The Patrick Matt David podcast I
just thought that was uh that was pretty
funny I was with Adam at the beginning
of that thing and uh he's an interesting
guy because he's still a bit of a lefty
liberal trying to slog his way through
making sense of things hanging out with
a lot of scary right-wingers these days
but he does live in the Free State of
Florida and I think that I can get him
over the hump as I am one to do you know
rescuing the old liberals and bringing
them to the promised land anyway thank
you guys for joining us on this late
edition of the Reuben report obviously
on the road we're doing things on the
fly in the Prager you folks uh were nice
enough to lend us the studio so thanks
to Dennis and everybody there uh we will
not have a post game show today I'm
doing a an interview with Dennis after
this it's not really an interview we're
just going to chat we're just gonna
catch up actually and we will air that
tomorrow at our regular time 11 A.M
Eastern and with all of that out of the
way the theme today is my brutally
honest take on what happened at that
Republican debate yesterday we're going
to show you one clip one highlight so to
speak of each of the candidates and then
I will as I will promise you I always
try to be and we'll always continue to
try to be I will be as brutally honest
you guys you guys know my opinions and
my thoughts and feelings on most of
these candidates and who I like and who
I kind of don't like and who I sometimes
like and all the rest of it uh but I
will just be as honest as I can be some
of you are going to like me more some of
you are going to like me less that's all
I can do right that's it's as simple as
that uh so we're gonna go through uh the
debate last night and also a little bit
of just sort of the format and how it
all just feels so old and stodgy and
it's just not working anymore the the
very system around the whole thing and
then we've got a Community Q a uh from
our friends over at
reubenreport.locals.com so let's just
dive right into it we will start with
the guy who is at Center Stage because
he is polling at number two of course
that's Florida Governor Ron DeSantis uh
the guy who is polling apparently at
number one Donald Trump decided not to
show up again and uh the odd thing
about the DeSantis performance and then
I'll throw to the clip and we can talk
about it the odd thing about the
DeSantis performance last night was even
though he is you know the number one guy
Center Stage center of the stage right
there uh he was not called on for 16
minutes and you could really I'm sure
you guys felt it at home but I'm telling
you in that room you could really feel
it everybody in the room by two by the
time two or three minutes had gone on
and Tim Scott had talked a whole bunch
and Vivek had talked and Pence had
talked and I think Nikki had talked
everybody in the room for the first few
minutes was like what is going on here
uh anyway here was a nice moment uh when
they were all talking about woke stuff
and who would do what DeSantis finally
kind of broke in and said what I have
wanted to hear him say all along here's
the thing is fine interesting Ron let me
finish this
here's the fact
I hate a lot of the things they're
saying Nikki the only one up here who's
gotten in the big fights and is
delivered big victories for the people
of Florida and that's what it's it's all
about I've Done It While others have
talked about it all right so I'm going
to give you a little criticism of
DeSantis as well but I want to start
with that moment because that I think is
what we have needed more of look he's
not the flashiest obviously right he's
not going to get you with the great
Zinger or the great off the cuff remark
what he can get you with I think is and
what I hope America will come around to
is competence and Clarity and a track
record that I think is basically
unrivaled so at that moment they were
all talking about who's going to fight
the woken how are you going to get
wokeness out of schools and what are you
going to do about the trans kids and all
of the stuff and everyone's saying what
they'll do and he was right he has done
it and not only has he fought the woken
we've removed so much of this nonsense
from our school systems in Florida and
we've got an ESG out of our institutions
and our banking systems in Florida as
you know and a whole bunch more he's
done it he's taken the slings from the
mainstream media he's taken the slings
from some of his competitors right there
I want to mention one thing you know
when DeSantis was fighting Disney all
along let's not forget we showed you a
clip many times of Mike Pence saying
repeatedly that you know this was a bit
of a overuse of government power pushing
back against Disney even though all
DeSantis was doing was stripping special
rights and Privileges and tax exemptions
from Disney he was making the playing
field even which is what every American
especially what every conservative would
want but Pence was going the more
corporatist route by the way Nikki Haley
said almost the exact same thing and
Vivek repeatedly has said over the last
couple months that that DeSantis lost to
Disney simply untrue so anyway I think
that was really probably desantis's best
moment because that's what what most
people want out of him which is will you
as president govern the country the way
you have governed Florida because no
matter what anyone says about Florida no
matter what Trump says in the rest of it
everyone knows that it is the freest
most flourishing State well I suppose
not everybody there's an awful lot of
blue build people but you got it people
who are somewhat awake all of that being
said I do have to to lay some criticism
at DeSantis which is he needs more than
one little breakout moment you know
there's a very odd thing happening at
these debates because if we are to
believe that the the polls to any degree
then Trump is way ahead right now again
it's a long game we get to Iowa and if
anyone else besides Trump wins Iowa or
if it's even close all of the polls are
completely out of the window but the
Trump thing looms large over the entire
thing and what I want to see out of
DeSantis more so it's not I don't care
for the zingers I think it would help on
social media if you had a few more of
them and you know and I think he maybe
could be a little more aggressive when
people are talking over each other
although they usually look kind of silly
and several times he was like Hey does
anyone want to hear this nonsense and I
do think that sums it up nicely but what
I want to see out of DeSantis and if I
get a chance and then maybe at the Miami
debate or wherever else I will say it to
him and his campaign people is everyone
in that room and almost everyone
watching at home knows he's the only guy
that has a chance against Trump right
Tim Scott does not honestly think he has
a chance against Trump I think maybe
Nikki honestly thinks she does and I'll
we'll talk about them in a moment uh but
but Pence knows this thing's not going
anywhere Christy doesn't think he's
going to be president vivec I don't
think thinks he's going to be president
right
DeSantis is the one
if if it's at all possible and he needs
to do something that is going to
separate him from the pack isn't it
interesting that no one really goes
after him at these things because his
track record is pretty damn uh it's
pretty damn airtight
but he needs to to basically turn to
everybody and be like guys cut the
if we have any chance to move this party
in this country past Trump take the good
things from Maga and Trump respect what
he did but do it in a much cleaner
tighter way then it's me and you all
know it and let's just stop with all
this stuff I think that he needs as an
elderly gentleman pretending to be
president often says he needs a backbone
like a ramrod okay and I would like to
see that backbone like a ramrod so that
would be my assessment of of desantis's
performance he did performance he did
not quite do that but again he didn't
get dinged I didn't hear him lie once he
effectively communicated his ideas
although uh the the moderators certainly
did not go to him enough and just
briefly on the moderators yeah I don't
think they did a great job I happen to
like Dana Perino a lot to do her show
she's a great gal and I think she's a
good broadcaster I think they just lost
control especially uh Tim Scott and
Nikki constantly talking over everybody
Pence did it a little bit Vivek does it
a lot they just lost control and they
have to figure out a way and we all see
it right it does it feels old and stale
and weird the zingers that don't work
the pre-packaged lines it hasn't caught
up with the way the internet talks about
things and but that's that's a bit of an
aside uh the the main moment with vivec
was sort of the best and worst of Vivek
at the exact same time which he seems to
be doing a lot of uh this is him talking
about Tick Tock how he used to talk
about banning Tick Tock then he hung out
with the tick tocker so now he's saying
you should get on Tick Tock or that he
should be on Tick Tock but also that
when he becomes president he'll ban Tick
Tock try to make any sense of that here
you go you joined Tick Tock after dinner
with boxer and influencer Jake Paul
should the commander-in-chief be so
easily persuaded by an influencer so the
answer is I have a radical idea for the
Republican party we need to win
elections and part of how we win
elections is reaching the next
generation of Young Americans where they
are so when I get into office I've been
very clear kids under the age of social
under the age of 16 should not be using
addictive social media there's exactly
one person in the Republican party which
talks a big game about reaching young
people and that's me and let me level
with all of you I'm the new guy here and
so I know I have to earn your trust what
do you see you see a young man who's in
a bit of a hurry maybe a little
ambitious bit of a know-it-all it seems
at times I'm here to tell you no I don't
know it all I will listen all right so
there's a couple things there first off
just at the at the purely policy level I
don't know what right the president has
to say who can or cannot be on social
media and what age that should happen at
right that's up for parents to decide
for kids kids and an adult to decide for
themselves so it's an odd Flex like as
president I will say at 16 years old you
can get on Tick Tock but before you can
he went on to say that he was going I
mean the the idea that he was trying to
communicate there was that he was
against Tick Tock because it's Chinese
spyware he flat out says it everyone on
the stage agrees with him the moderators
agree we all know it but now he's saying
we have to get on Chinese spyware so
that we can win elections meaning his
idea then would be go to where young
people are so young people are using
Chinese spyware so I'll use Chinese
spyware then once I have the power I
will ban Chinese spyware and and I think
a phrase that I'm going to be saying a
lot over the next uh course of the year
of this election primary and general is
do the ends justify the means
I don't think so I know a lot of people
do think so and in politics almost
everyone does right like you should do
whatever you can to win at all costs but
to me that is what would put us on the
slow descent to hell I believe that the
means how you get there are important it
is important to get to the end but how
you go about doing it with integrity and
honesty and everything else so I think
he's being a little short-sighted there
I get it why he wants to be on Tick Tock
he wants to be cool amongst young people
and he wants to get the whatever the
read tick tocks what do they call them
on Tick Tock the tickle tackle tickled
Whatever Whatever It Is Well I'm not on
Tick Tock we have an account which I
told my guys we don't even have to have
a tick tock account if you don't want
and Brock my social media guy said I'll
do it I'll put the social the Chinese
spyware on my phone so God bless him for
that
um but I truly did not pressure anyone
to do it anyway the point is the idea
that you would do something that you
think is evil using Chinese spyware
encourage young people to do it and say
well that's where they are so I'm gonna
go and then I'll ban it after no I just
don't think that thing flies and he was
explaining it the audience was not with
him and then Nikki Haley had I would say
her best Zinger of the night in response
to that okay there's one person on this
side this is infuriating because because
Tick Tock is one of the most dangerous
social media apps that we could have and
what you've got I honestly every time I
hear you I feel a little bit Dumber for
what you say because I can't believe
they hear me Tick Tock situation what
they're doing is these 150 million
people are on Tick Tock that means they
can get your contacts they can get your
financial information they can get your
email thank you let me just say text
messages
this is very important exactly all right
that that's a good moment from Nikki you
know all the pre-packaged stuff and
maybe she had the line waiting
everything every time I listen to you I
feel a little bit Dumber it's like maybe
she had that waiting but it didn't come
off as super pre-packaged and look the
show does matter a little bit here right
if you land the line correctly uh people
are into it that's what goes viral
that's what gets a little of the
internet Zeitgeist going and we're going
to show you a moment where a line did
not go as well as that but in essence
what she was saying there was the ends
don't justify the means yes you want to
get young people and she explained that
a little bit further but you don't do it
by using an app that the CCP the
Communist Party of China is using to
steal banking information and all sorts
of stuff from adults and young people
alike so that was a nice moment for her
I'd also like to say that on the Nikki
front uh look I have a major
disagreement with her on the Ukraine
thing I do not believe we can endlessly
fund this thing I have a lot of
reservations about zelenski and the
Ukrainian government and their attacks
on free speech and banning political
parties and postponing elections and all
of that stuff that is not a defensive
Russia by the way for the people that
seem to be confused about that somehow
if you if you say anything uh in that
regard it makes it you know a certain
set of people think that you're suddenly
pro-russia that's obviously not the case
um but Nikki I think came across as
fairly competent she was strong she
forced her way in and some people
thought she was a bit aggressive but she
still remains my Dark Horse here if
someone was to rise out of the pack and
again that's putting the foreign policy
stuff aside and you have to remember not
everyone you watching this let's say you
roughly agree with me on foreign policy
stuff and maybe you don't that's great
actually and I know you guys have all
sorts of different opinions that doesn't
mean that all Americans feel that same
way so when I say that I see a lot of
people I don't agree with her on that
and how could you say that David I'm
trying to give you an honest assessment
I'm not trying to say that every
candidate who's going to rise to the top
is just going to agree with me on
everything so that would be that uh Tim
Scott who got a lot of talk time
yesterday I don't know if they did the
clock they usually do a clock of talk
time he had a lot of talk to him he also
speaks pretty slowly so that probably
extended it but he had a good line here
I thought when it came to uh they were
talking originally about
um the unions and then he's kind of
turned that into something about
immigration I'll say this Joe Biden
should not be on the picket line he
should be on the southern border working
to close our Southern border because it
is unsafe wide open event and insecure
leading to the deaths of 70
000 Americans in the last 12 months
because of fentanyl it is devastating
every County in America is now a border
County because fentanyl has devastated
Americans in every single state okay I
think that was a pretty good shift of
topic you know they always figure out a
way you get yeah get asked the question
and you can just answer any other
question so that was about Joe Biden
being on the line with some of these
Detroit Auto Workers right now the union
line but the way he shifted it to what
most people care about right now and I'm
not diminishing what's going on in
Detroit right now but most people I
think the thing that's on most people's
mind right now it's it's the economy and
it's the border and this border
situation is completely out of control
and I would argue at this point that no
Administration could be this incompetent
thus it is an actual intentional
Invasion when we've shown you many of
these videos of border patrol officers
oh come on in sorry we let 10 in you
guys are gonna have to wait a minute oh
you want to go to Chicago it would
probably be better to go to San Diego
like all of this stuff like to me it's
obvious and it's intentional but I think
I think he did a nice job there uh I
don't think he wanted to talk about the
picket line too much and to shift it to
to a weakness of uh of Biden was a good
move I would say Tim Scott although look
I think realistically he probably has
two more debates in and maybe only one
more you know there's a certain I will
talk about this with Pence as well who's
coming up next like these guys no one
thinks they're going to be president
they are there for a little bit and it
widens the field and everything else but
Tim Scott did a fairly decent job of
getting up there and being someone that
people were listening to last night
let's go to former VP Mike Pence this
was a confusing moment at the uh
at the debate last night that made
everyone in the room slightly
uncomfortable it's my way of full
disclosure Chris you've mentioned the
president's situation I'm
my wife
isn't a member of the teachers union but
I got to admit I'm
I've been sleeping with a teacher for 38
years and the full disclosure
yeah nobody like the Laugh was weird it
was paused he was struggling to choke
that line out it was a little unclear if
his wife is the teacher he's been
sleeping with a lot of people thought
that several of them were sleeping with
Randy Weingarten who's the teachers
union president who's also a lesbian
there's a lot of layers to this whole
thing uh but look offense again he's
probably just like a decent guy he's a
little more let's say conservative for
me on some stuff but nobody really knows
why He's there it seems to me he's
trying to clean up a little bit of what
maybe he thinks is his tarnished
reputation related to Trump uh but
there's no real support there my guess
is he has two debates in him if not just
the next one in Miami very similar to
the Tim Scott situation uh the other guy
is North Dakota governor Doug bergram
and Doug who uh nobody seems to know but
actually is a pretty nice guy he's got
incredible eyebrows if you take anything
away from this he also injured himself
before the last debate in a basketball
uh accident which I'm very sympathetic
to he's wearing the boot he still had
the boot you probably didn't see that at
home but we saw it in the room uh anyway
there's no real point in showing any of
his policy stuff although I thought it
was all actually pretty decent uh here
was just a moment where he would not
stop talking and Dana Perino finally
couldn't take it anymore Stuart can we
get back to the
I don't want to do it but somebody else
is going to do it I don't actually have
the button but there are tech people
over there who have it so I don't think
we have to talk about that much more uh
again he actually does seem like a nice
guy it seems like North Dakota is doing
quite well and he's uh he's a fairly
decent Communicator actually but it's
just not going to happen I'm pretty sure
that was his last debate so let's go
let's move on that uh Chris Christie had
a moment that every single person in
that room and I would guess millions of
people millions of people across America
cringed as he choked out this line and I
want to look at that camera right now
and tell you Donald I know you're
watching you can't help yourself I know
you're watching okay and you're not here
tonight not because of polls and not
because of your indictments you're not
here tonight because you're afraid of
being on the stage and Defending Your
record you're ducking these things and
let me tell you what it's going to
happen you keep doing that no one up
here is going to call you Donald Trump
anymore we're going to call you Donald
Duck all right
everybody was like uh okay like I'm
pretty sure that Disney in a weird way
I'm siding with Disney on this one they
should sue
that man over this like just enough is
enough
um look I actually agree with the
sentiment there I really do Trump is
ducking this stuff because he's afraid
it is not healthy for a democracy to
have the front runner the man who wants
to lead the world and go up against
Putin and ji and all of these people not
debate and I get the Strategic version
of it and it's also why I said I'm going
to be repeating the phrase do you
believe the ends justify the means do
you believe you can do anything you want
in the quest for power duck debates lie
about people etc etc that has been my
criticism of trump so I actually do
agree with the heart of what Christie
said there but these pre-packaged lines
they just do not work okay in any event
uh that that is a one clip of everybody
now I want to show you one other clip
because one other politician was in the
building and you knew he was there
because you could smell the sulfur yes
that's right California governor Gavin
Newsom and the debate was in Simi Valley
in California so it was his state but it
was a little bizarre to have him show up
he showed up he was in the spin room Fox
put him on for an interview it was Sean
Hannity right after like to me this is
the system showing Biden the door one
way or another and it's clearly going to
be Newsome or they're at least laying
the groundwork for all of that and here
is Newsom uh actually backing his buddy
Trump and let's not forget that Gavin
newsom's ex-wife and and I happen to
like her so this is not a personal shot
at anybody Kimberly Guilfoyle
were friendly we've had dinner she's a
really nice gal but his ex-wife is
Donald Trump Jr's current wife and
here's Newsom uh saying Trump was the
winner Governor what do you think is
going to be the takeaway after this
debate from the American people I think
it will be clear that Trump comes out
the dominant Force after this debate I
mean this is the XFL this is Jake I mean
and honestly I mean this is maybe maybe
a vice presidential debate these guys
are getting laughed by Donald Trump it's
not even close it's not even interesting
and I think what's most interesting to
me is do they recognize that or are they
actually going to show up and run
against the guy that's in the way of
their prospects to be the nominee it's a
zero-sum game it's a binary choice at
the end of the day it's not a ranked
Choice voting
so either these guys come after the
front runner and distinguish themselves
or otherwise they're wasting everybody's
time and I say this with love and
respect there's a reason some of the
advertising is being discounted for this
debate people don't even want to tune in
because they know that fundamental he
says it with love and respect man that
he is the most slimy disingenuous
dishonest perfect Democrat of all time
and that's why they are prepping him to
take over for Joe Biden he is deeply
inauthentic I truly believe he is a
lizard person I think if you peeled off
his skin there would be a cold-blooded
lizard there no offense to lizards who
have become quite fond of while I live
in the Free State of Florida right now
okay I I love the iguanas sure they're
fighting with Clyde in the backyard and
we lose tails and it's a bloody mess out
there I I like them certainly a lot more
than I like avenuesome but the fact that
he was there Fox puts him on with
Hannity and more importantly than
anything else let's not forget what
Donald Trump said about Gavin Newsom
during coven I couldn't really hit him
because he was saying nice things about
me remember that and now Gavin Newsom
saying nice things about Trump and do
you think that maybe guys 4D chess
people out there do you think that maybe
Gavin Newsom saying nice things about
Trump because everybody knows that Trump
is the most beatable candidate Trump
can't bring in any new people and
DeSantis actually could and he's done it
in Florida so the entire freaking
machine is trying to make sure Trump
shouldn't have to debate because look at
the polls look at everybody else and
Gavin Newsom and MSNBC are on the same
side as Donald Trump when it comes to
Ron DeSantis do you think there might be
a little something there
I leave that to you wise people all
right let's get to a
reubenreport.locals.com community q a
Lloyd says do you think debates should
have Mike cutoffs so they it's a little
unclear like who's in charge of that and
again I don't think Dana was there like
pressing the button there's somebody in
a in a booth somewhere that's actually
pressing the button or they're lowering
the mic at times look they lost complete
control there was so much talking over
each other DeSantis as I referenced
earlier he had a nice moment where he
was like guys is this you think this is
what anyone wants but you could barely
hear him over what usually was Tim Scott
and Nikki Haley arguing and the funny
thing about them arguing and you can see
why they're doing it is that South
Carolina
Phoenix can you check this for me South
Carolina is number three in the primary
process is it Iowa New Hampshire and
then South Carolina I'm pretty sure it
is three let's not forget he's a sitting
Senator she's a former governor of South
Carolina so there is something to fight
for there if they're both in it still at
that time right
um but I think you have to have a better
system altogether you don't need three
moderators there was simply no reason
for that imagine if Tucker had done that
just one man I could do it it doesn't
have to be me Rogan could do it whoever
you could maybe have two people but I
think too many moderators and just there
was not anyone that was going to say I
am in control of this thing and I would
say that would be my criticism of
DeSantis he needed to say I'm in control
of this thing and I would also say it's
the criticism I have for the moderators
they have to say I'm in control of this
thing yes South Carolina is the third
one uh Tony says has Clyde had any more
iguana incidences or he is or is he
enjoying retirement undefeated I sort of
just answered that Clyde is constantly
fighting with iguanas outside bloody
mess I got bloody iguanas in the pool
there's some frog fights uh but he's
loving it he really is loving life like
he's a different dog than he was in L.A
La where I used to live about a mile
from here you know everything's dead
here nothing really grows here it's kind
of just dirty and it's just not you got
my feelings about this place but Florida
there's so much life there he constantly
has a bird to Chase and he'll kill a
bird or a squirrel and he's just like
he's like finding his inner animal which
I think is probably the uh the purpose
of all animals Harry says what were your
thoughts on the moderators last night
well I basically answered that already I
just think you just need stronger
personalities that's not a knock on any
of them specifically but it's partly
that the the system itself doesn't work
you know these things are not a debate a
debate would be
something like this it would be like
please explain
um why you believe capitalism is the
best economic system uh and then you'd
say okay you DeSantis you can go first
because you're polling highest and then
you'd have people chiming in and you
would talk that out for 10 minutes right
and everybody would get a little chance
in somebody would say something somebody
would get to respond they're doing this
thing where it's like to say this will
you we ask you this question then one
guy can go after you for that and then
Nikki will ask you a completely
different question and let two people
fight about that and you we're gonna ask
you something answer a completely
different question than you're asked and
and for other it's not a debate it's
just like this constant show of
they're like juggling poop basically and
when you juggle poop Connor what happens
you get poop in your face I haven't
tried it that's what he said
that's good uh Glenn says which state
has better weather Florida or California
look
I am here in SoCal it is 78 and
beautiful today but I got to tell you in
La the air quality is absolutely
terrible one of the things we used to
live here in LA and I know it's easy for
me to crap on La all the time
um but when we used to live here in L.A
the weather was beautiful all the time
but we did not sit Outdoors on our
outdoor furniture that often because
there the air quality is so bad that
there would be like a constant like soot
or dust on everything even though the
air quality was really nice we do our we
do our thing outside but like I just
didn't sit on we didn't hang out outside
that often actually uh where in La uh in
Florida it rains all the time you know
we just passed the Summer where you'd
get these storms virtually every day for
a few minutes and then it'd be sunny and
then a storm again but everything's
clean and fresh and growing and
everything else I know that's I'm just
comparing the weather of La Northern
Cali is a little bit different and
cooler and everything else
I just love Florida I just love Florida
to each his own as they say I don't mind
humidity I like a little I like sweating
a little bit like getting out there and
sweating
um Florida's hot in the summer it is
what it is but yeah there you go uh we
can save America 24 says what advice
would you give Robert Kennedy Junior
especially with the crap from the DNC
look he is almost at the end of the road
which I predicted he would be at about
six months ago that the when what did I
say I mean find my first video we should
find it at some point my first video
whenever he was put on the map I said by
the time the DNC is done with him he
will basically be a republican I don't
think that means he will be a laminated
card-carrying member of the Republican
party but he will be done with the
Democrats he is seeing in real time How
Deeply corrupt these people are that
they if he campaigns in Iowa or the
early States they automatically give his
votes to Biden because they know that
Biden by the by the nature of being the
incumbent does not have to campaign at
all they are so freaking corrupt look
the Republicans are stupid they're not
that great they're always going to
disappoint you but generally speaking
they're not just downright evil and
corrupt to the core some of them are but
as of general rule the Democrats are and
I think my advice to him at the end
would be there's just such a great path
right if DeSantis becomes president then
you know what you do you bring in RFK
and RFK is tasked with taking down the
agencies
figure out what's going on at the CIA
and the FBI find out what's going on
with fauci and the NIH and CDC and all
those things do what his life's work has
been as a lawyer and fighting the
machine in that regard that would be a
beautiful thing he just won't do it with
Trump so I know a lot of you are
probably thinking that he just won't do
it he's repeatedly said that George says
is there anything you miss about
California
you know what I'm going to dinner
tonight
at a a joint on uh Sunset oh wait a
minute I can't say the name of the place
it's here so it doesn't really matter
but I'm having dinner at a place I used
to like you know what I miss Dennis I
miss Marissa some of the people here we
had some great friends here and now they
usually visit us in Florida but we had a
nice life we really did have a nice life
here even at the height of the insanity
with covet I was running illegal parties
all the time I was you know bring it was
like you know it was like the
Underground Railroad of Sanity bringing
people to our house we had a really nice
life here what I always said what
happened in the four walls of our house
was always wonderful it was just
stepping outside that I couldn't take
anymore so yes I do have some fond
memories but Cali is what it is at this
point Florida man Chuck says we know the
debates are generally very proper but if
you had the opportunity to go down the
list of candidates and ask them each and
anything goes questioned what would it
be is what's very simple I would
literally say when was the last time you
got laid
now apparently it's happening to Mike
Pence a lot it's a little unclear
whether it's his wife or another teacher
but wouldn't that just be interesting
like really let's go through each one
bergram when do you think bergram
Burger's probably I feel like he's in a
decent marriage he seems like a happy
guy I bet you bergram's getting laid
every now and again I'm gonna say for
bergram
two weeks it's been about two weeks he's
oh and he's got the uh he's got the cast
on his leg in the boot so you know
uh two weeks for burgram okay Christy
when's the last time Christy got laid 20
years 20 years 20 years uh yeah I mean
that one I guess just nobody wants to
picture it sorry like whatever you know
it is what it is like that it's probably
been a while it's probably been a while
like you can see it you know
um who else was up there Nikki you know
Nikki often fondly talks about her
husband and her marriage and I've gotten
to know her personally a little bit I
feel like they have like a kind of
healthy sex life I really do actually
she strikes me as like she seems like a
full woman to me you know what I mean
and it's tough being up there with all
the men I I think Nikki probably I want
to say one week Nikki Haley okay uh
let's see Pence I mean the 38 years like
Pence I don't know it was in a room but
nobody else was with him and there was
someone in another room or something
like that and they said they said they
did it uh Tim Scott well I guess it
would depend where the where the
girlfriend is nobody seems to know where
this Canadian maybe it was High School
uh maybe it was in the Boy Scouts you
know who knows who knows
um vivec you know Vivek look vivex young
what is he 30 six something like that
like and he seems his wife seems nice
and she's pretty they've got two young
kids that's hitting it I'm going to save
a vac within five days uh and DeSantis
you know to say this I will say this
DeSantis doesn't like reek of like like
male energy in that way but I will tell
you this I have been to many events with
with him and Casey and you know had had
some whiskey with them and I'll tell you
what they I don't even know that they'd
ever want me to say this but I will say
this and I think it I think it honestly
it bodes well for them we were at an
event one night about a year ago and it
was after the event it was like an
all-day event and there were all sorts
of people there and whatever and it was
me and the two of them and I think one
or two other people and I was doing my
tequila and they were I I think they
were both having whiskey if I'm not
mistaken or maybe she you know I don't
think she was drinking actually but I
think he had a whiskey and uh and she
said you know this is our date night
this is what date night looks looks like
to us and I immediately I turned to both
of them and I said gov if it's date
night you better get out of here just
like that I smiled at him they both knew
exactly what I meant and he looked at
her and he smiled and he said honey
let's go and they walked right out
so I'm gonna guess that they're having a
little fun on uh on the road so there oh
so I have to oh and they also have three
young kids so I'm gonna say I'm gonna
say also I'm gonna give them the vivec
thing it's within about five days or so
uh Mitchell says have you discovered any
cool tequila recipes actual tequila
itself or tequila drinks during your
tequila Journey so far so yes we are
moving ahead and working on this tequila
uh you know we're working on a Reposado
which takes a couple months to age and
we really want to get it right so if if
the one that uh that we have Brewing is
not quite right we're going to change
the taste I've told you guys a little
bit about some of my thinking behind it
of whether we go with like just
something super clean and simple now I'm
thinking we go something a little more
high-end because I want people to really
appreciate tequila I think it's just
such a nice thing to just Sip and you
don't have to drink a lot of it and it's
just got a nice vibe to it and taste and
all that
um
one thing that I found when we were in
Mexico a couple weeks ago and we were
tasting a whole bunch of things we found
another alcohol called cetol s-o-t-o-l
uh tequila is made from Agave obviously
so tall is made from an agave-like plant
but it's not the same as tequila but
it's got a really earthy uh cactus-like
flavor really really nice to sip on and
I actually found I found a restaurant a
Mexican joint in Miami that has some and
it's really really nice check it out if
you haven't Ben says is the VP going to
come from the current field or will it
be a surprising candidate it's a great
question I mean at first it depends who
the president is I would say if it's
Trump you know I hear the the Trump
people always are like it's got to be
Curry Lake it's got to be Curry Lake
it's not going to be Kyrie Lake I'm
sorry if you're Carrie Lake Trump if it
is Trump he has to go to someone to
widen the tent right you have to go to
somebody else you don't go to Cary Lake
just so that you have more of the same
you got to go to somebody else by the
way quick story on Cary Lake you you
know I hit Carrie Lake a couple times
hard over the weekend that sounded like
an answer to the other question uh
Carrie was on the pbd podcast as you saw
and she was really going after DeSantis
in a really dishonest way about closing
beaches and that he took a page out of
newsom's book during Kobe just more of
the lies that Trump has been exporting
about DeSantis and kovid she got owned
repeatedly on Twitter and everywhere
else we put up a video of her like we it
was really nice what we did we took a
video of her saying that DeSantis wanted
beaches closed and we put that up and
then we just found it was so easy to
find it took us literally like three
minutes a video of trump calling for
DeSantis to close the beaches down
anyway so we hit her a couple times on
on Twitter over that she came up to me
and she at the debate and she was
clearly not happy with me and she's like
Dave don't take it so personally and I
was like well I do take it personally
because I moved to Florida because of
freedom and because of the santis and
these policies and it wasn't true what
you were saying and she's like she's
like you know well I don't know truth
does matter and um and then and then I
said uh oh and she said and you know
DeSantis just wasn't good and we can't
rewrite we can't rewrite history and I
said do you know and I'm pretty sure I'm
doing this like as verbatim as I can uh
I said you do know that fauci got an
award from Trump on his last day in
office and she goes he did she goes well
I think he gave one to Trump too and
then she walked away and I was like what
like I'm pretty sure she did do we know
that Trump gave like
just made it up anywho it's not going to
be Gary I'm sorry to tell you Carrie
um I think Trump would have to do
something how do you how do you bring in
the moderates like I think a wise move
would be someone like
um Tulsi gabbard but I just don't think
she would be associated with Trump so I
I don't know where Trump goes I think
DeSantis probably has to do something
for the base so this if you're DeSantis
do you go to a careersty gnome maybe a
Christy gnome I think that's maybe a
possibility I you know the the one that
I think DeSantis I think he really likes
her and I really like her and I've met
her a couple times we had her on the
show is Iowa governor
um oh I'm sorry Kim Reynolds uh I think
she's
um
I think she's really she's bright and
smart she gets it she's like chipper and
fun and I think she'd be a nice blend
and she's extremely popular in Iowa now
obviously you don't announce your VP
before you've won a couple things so it
would be Irrelevant for the primary but
I think that could be an interesting one
for him uh Quinn says can you find a
nice place in LA to show us yes it's the
place I'm going to dinner tonight that I
can't tell you about but I will tell you
in a future episode because I can't have
everybody showing up to where I'm having
dinner thank you very much Janice says
where else is nice in L.A let me think
of something nice
um you know what uh the Hollywood Bowl
which is an outdoor Amphitheater here
that I saw a bunch of concerts at over
the years the coolest one I saw by far
they do it every year I think a couple
times a year uh John Williams you know
the incredible composer John Williams
who did Star Wars at Jurassic Park and
you know every great soundtrack of
Indiana Jones from from the 80s into
today uh they do all of his music with
the LA Philharmonic and you know when
they do Star Wars especially you
basically have like 3 000 people all
with lightsabers doing a light show that
was that was a really awesome moment in
Los Angeles Janice says what do you
think will happen on real time when
DeSantis and Sam Harris go on well I
will be there uh I am still not on the
show for whatever reason Bill uh but I
will be there I will be backstage and I
will talk to the gov and I'll talk to
Sam if Sam will still talk to me I I
don't hold anything personally against
him as I said uh but you know Sam is
hasn't been talking much I guess to some
of the old crew uh in terms of what will
happen with them there will be nothing
public that happens with them because I
assume uh the way well you know what I
don't know for sure because now that the
show is back without the writers there's
going to be a different format
altogether but my my guess is the
governor is going to do a one-on-one
with Bill and then Sam will be part of a
panel so I don't think there'll be any
direct interaction between Sam Harris
and the governor although I think it
would be nice if there was because it
would be pretty great to see the gov
kind of going at it with Sam and Bill
you know two kind of liberals let's say
who maybe quite haven't figured out
exactly what's going on here in reality
just yet uh Liz says can we do a meet
and greet in Los Angeles next time I
don't know when next time will be but
yes we will we will try to do that for
sure Sam says are you going to Arc in
London yes Arc is Jordan Peterson's
conference that is a 180 counter a
counter conference to the world economic
Forum uh it's the alliance for
responsible citizenship he is doing that
at the end of October into early
November so I will be in London for
about a week and everybody
like probably 40 people that have been
on this show will be there a bunch of
conferences it's open to the public I
think you can get tickets if you just
Google our conference or maybe we can
put the description the link in the
description if you guys want to come to
that and there's going to be some big
dinners and I think Jordan's been very
good about like who can do what there so
I think I'm going to give a talk on kind
of new media and politics that sort of
thing but everyone's going to kind of
pick their specialty and do different
things and it's I think it's going to be
held actually at a couple of different
venues so I'm really I'm really really
looking forward to that and it would be
nice to just get a sane clear counter to
the world economic forum
Kevin says if the view invited you onto
their show would you do it yes
absolutely 100 I think it would be
hilarious at this point I would be ready
to roll right I would bring the receipts
as I always say Ted Cruz went to the
view and when they asked him about some
stuff election denial he was like how
about this I would be ready to go I
would try to be decent and honest to
them I would tell joy joy I used to love
you you know it because we used to talk
uh whoopee like you know
ghost come on Sister Act Two you used to
be okay like what happened here the one
I would struggle with is Hannah because
she is such a freaking liar and she
lives in the Free State of Florida while
ranting and raving that this place is
horrible and you know she's married to a
guy that's worth like hundreds of
millions of bucks if I'm not mistaken uh
and like super rich she she once we got
into it on Twitter once and she drives a
Maserati the woman the woman's living
the life while pretending she's living
in a gulag and I would have a just
harder time because the Florida thing
again it just feels personal to me uh
versus some of the other stuff I would
also ask the blonde woman what her name
is because nobody knows what her name is
and then there's the the sellout
Republican I don't think I would look at
her it would be we could give her the
day off uh Mary says how do you think
they will make Newsom the nominee look
this is the gajillion dollar question
it's so obviously happening the question
is when not if and Biden even if they
get Biden through the election he
obviously is not going to be president
for another four years I am not
convinced they will get him through the
election or that he could break down at
any moment as I'm speaking right now
breaks a hip it's over right
um what are they gonna do
look it would be ironic as all hell but
I would not put anything past these evil
devil worshipers how they would the
Democrats would be the one to get rid of
the first black female VP and and
basically stop her from also being the
first black female president but they
will figure out a way what Gavin could
maybe do or what they could do is let's
let's say Biden
steps down the impeachment stuff gets
too hot or there's just too much
corruption or the health or whatever or
they just say there's a bunch of stuff
here we don't think you're going to win
the election or something we're just
pushing you aside what you could do is
you temporarily put Kamala in everyone
feels oh my God we got the black female
vice president it's the greatest day
ever Hallelujah okay fine you have a
little moment of that and then what you
do is you do something like say that
Kamala has decided
that she actually she wants to spend
more time with what's her husband's Doug
I think too you want to spend more time
with Doug and do they have kids I guess
they have a kid probably they probably
have a transsexual son daughter or
something like you probably want to
spend more with he or they and she's
just going to step aside and what Gavin
could do is then you get Dianne
Feinstein who's 8 000 years old to step
down and you make Kamala Harris a
senator again from California like she
wants to be back in Cali she doesn't
want to be in DC something like that or
you don't even put her in politics
anymore you make her the head of the
non-profit the global Clinton Global
initiative you the Kamala Harris Society
for studying big States for small states
or concentric circles or whatever it
might be Venn diagrams you just get her
out of the way and then Newsome's the
one that's running and then Newsome
brings in somebody like I don't know
what it is
but don't pretend they can't do it I
hear a lot of people being like it's too
late it's not going to happen you know
Newsome's just a showboater give the
devil his due ladies and gentlemen give
the devil his due all right thank you
guys for submitting questions uh over at
the locals Community
reubenreport.locos.com as always part
two of my interview with Patrick Bett
David is up across platforms full things
up ad free over at locals and uh
tomorrow uh we will we will not be live
but at 11 A.M Eastern we will have a
regularly scheduled program it's going
to be a chat that I'm going to do I
don't know if we're doing in this room
or a different studio with Dennis Prager
I have no plans no paper no plans no
questions I'm just going to sit down
with an old friend and talk about the
state of the world we'll put that up at
11 A.M Eastern we leave you with a cold
close of the elderly man pretending to
be president and I will see everyone
tomorrow closer you mentioned Liz Cheney
throughout this process before your
testimony during it and after as an
inspiration to you and then one of the
few people who was by your side and you
could confide in how critical was Liz
Cheney in getting you to testify and how
good a strong of an ally was she
Les Cheney
is the leader that we all need to Aspire
X being she is the leader that we need
as a country to come together and find
people to Lux people like Liz Cheney
listen you have the spine of Steel and
she also cares deeply about this country
you know I think seeing was Cheney sits
on a dice with several Democratic
members of Congress goes to show how
dangerous of a moment that we are in as
a country
I would like to think that with Atlas
Junior sort of come to this moment but I
know that I came to this moment because
of this chain you know I'm forever
indebted to her for that and helping get
me to where I am today